do you talk to Obama still I was Obama's
favorite artist he actually met with me
Obama met with me and my mama to say
that he was running for office back in
2008.
um and that he wanted the support and
everybody was so into this idea of the
black president
and
we were always you were always cool and
it's also like
you know how many how many of us
are there you know Obama level yay level
you know Virgil level
um just
black
you know so brilliant that we cut
through all of the lines of racism like
you just can't get rid of his Nat King
Cole level uh Dave Chappelle level
so
in some place we'd have to be friends
and get along because it's like
yo you're at that level you're like a
you know Formula One Lewis Hamilton race
car driver we're still driving
a white car but we're the best race car
drivers uh that ever existed and that
was that was me and Obama's connection
but
soon as I wasn't saying the things that
I was supposed to say as a rapper
uh our connection faded
she don't talk to him anymore
I'll talk to him if I see him yep
but I guarantee he seen me
I didn't even know that man I just
thought that sound cool
[Laughter]
one idea that was in my head about three
minutes ago that I really want to say is
a
uh that's really interesting about
the uh when companies get the BLM
managers
what's a BLM manager black lives Matt
Black lives matter
uh office manager
is basically you get a semi-influential
black person to become the face of a
white company yeah right so that means
like in the design world
and the art World they actually would
pick
artists that were less talented than
other artists based on
their influence
uh not based on their actual work
because everyone is vying for influence
and an opinion
everyone is afraid of losing their
opinion
so with Nike right
Nike is as famous as you say Nike's more
famous than PayPal right yeah right what
what number company do you think PayPal
is I don't know number four
overall overall you got well you know
the number one is right it's Apple yeah
I'm beginning number two but number
three is
uh McDonald's
then
spacex's
maybe six or seven it's really
interesting that as lit as Elon is his
previous company is actually still worth
more than uh than SpaceX so
what number company do you think Nike is
the Nike
number 321 it's not there
to be
as big a financial company as it can be
it's there as an influencer because
black people love Nike
so
Nike is like a company that is redlining
and gerrymandering black people so the
reason why Gap wanted me to go the Gap
it wasn't based on
oh we need to get our stocks up
you know it's like these companies when
they've been around for a long time
gap's not like they're like we're in a
rag trade we're never going to be apple
and everyone all of these American
companies somehow took this this deal
where they start putting in these really
awkward weird number kind of CEOs like
Nike's got one
um
the Gap hat one it didn't work out and
there's all of these weird operators
inside of companies
even in Balenciaga you know
the
and they um
they're just there for control Steve
Jobs talked about it
it's the most important thing you can
have is control look at me
all the money all the influence and I
have to act at complete ass to have any
say so of anything that my children are
doing because
that group of people have control and
say so over all the children inside of
the clan
so
that's what these companies are set up
for that's the type of CEOs they're
hiring especially when the founders are
out of there they kind of just give the
companies up to a bunch of people and
they're all in cahoots
like anyone that ever worked with me
they just look at oh who's yay farming
for talent that we can hire to be our
new BLM
office manager
like kind of like Obama
what do you you think you think of Obama
as a BLM office manager
best whenever you know
best whenever and you know I think Obama
just like Virgil
these people were truly black to their
core and truly brilliant to their core
but they went into situations
thinking that they could do it the white
way
as a black man
and we saw what color Obama's hair was
when he went in and we saw what color it
was when when he went out
we know Virgil lost all his hair you
know and eventually passed away
so when I have techniques
that are revolutionary
if I raise my voice if I express myself
on Instagram
it's a colonic
and people can say oh that this is what
you're doing is toxic
if what I'm saying is toxic
I gotta do everything to get it out of
my body and there'll be times where I
see a level of like oppression Parisian
proper like next level you know France
owns 80 percent of African Banks level
colonization oppression and I'll be like
I'm not going to let you guys kill me
but one thing that has to really happen
say if Trump ran right
we're not just going to be black
influence
we're going to be
vision and creativity we've got to
rethink who we are as a species right
now we're we're we practice killing it
ourselves every day like murder is legal
in America
you know in abortion yes
uh
so
whoever
gets the position
needs to listen
to the vision I didn't know it was going
to rhyme when I first started they need
to have Elon
they need to have
me
that you should start with those two and
then we'll get to the rest of them they
could pull in a Johnny eyes or pull in
all of our living super brilliant people
and we need to analyze
and
and not just sell out for the cash like
these Fortune 500 companies are just
selling out for the cash and put God
first
and the best representation of God as
the children
the children is extension as family put
the families first there's so many
things suburbs
uh
the train tracks being ripped up by GM
just for capitalism all these ideas that
we have we're now living in place where
we're the Orphans of capitalism and we
just have to take a pause and rethink
how we can have the most beautiful
existence possible for our children for
the kids and we're all kids we're all
God's kids we're all sons of Abraham
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight